-We have exactly five shows left
before we go on Christmas break,
which means it's time for
that beloved
"Tonight Show" tradition.
It's time for "12 Days of
Christmas Sweaters."
-♪ 12 Days of
Christmas Sweaters ♪
♪ Five days left ♪
-That's right -- every show
between now and Christmas,
we'll be giving
one lucky audience member
an mm-mm-mm Christmas sweater
from the "Countdown to
Christmas Cabinet."
Since there are five shows left,
let's open door number 5.
Where do we go?
-Right here.
-Alright, go for it, bud.
Whenever you're ready.
Oh, my gosh!
Wow! I don't know what that is.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Is that a sweater?
[ Cheers and applause ]
I don't know what the heck --
-Turn it around?
-Yeah.
That's the back of it there.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah.
-Wow.
Alright. Wow!
-Oh, my gosh. This is heavy.
Alright, now let's see who's
going home -- Wow!
This is 100 pounds.
Let's see who's going home
with tonight's sweater.
Everyone look at your
seat number, okay?
If I call your number,
come on down.
Quest, can I get
a drumroll, please?
[ Drumroll ]
Who wants this sweater?
This is a...
[ Cheers and applause ]
314!
♪♪
Come on down.
Come on!
It's getting heavy.
Hey, come on,
we got a show to do.
Come on, get over here.
Here, go on over there.
Gosh, this sweater's heavy.
You take your time
with that one.
Gosh. Welcome.
-Oh, sorry.
-Thank you for coming.
Thank you for being here.
What is your name?
-Marcella.
-Marcella, where are you from?
-California.
-Hey!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Marcella, this is perfect
for California.
-Yeah.
-Everyone in L.A.
will be wearing these.
Do you have anything
like this at home?
-Nope.
-Oh! Nothing even close?
-Uh, no.
-Yeah.
Marcella, would you try this
on for us tonight?
-Yeah.
-Alright, cool.
Roots, can I get some music?
♪♪
We need some help here.
Alright, good luck.
I feel your head.
I feel your head in there.
Okay, good.
Marcel-- Oh! Can you breathe?
-Yeah.
-Yes, you're good. Alright.
Sorry.
-I'm, like, nervous.
-No, that's alright.
Oh, yeah, good, Marcella.
Yeah, gorgeous.
-Oh!
-No, this is perfect.
Marcella, turn around.
This is good.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, my gosh.
That is unbelievably gorgeous.
Beautiful.
Thank you so much, Marcella.
Congratulations.
Thank you very much.
-I just had an
ugly Christmas sweater, um...
-You just had an
ugly Christmas sweater party?
-Party.
-Yeah.
-And it's too late.
-Yeah, too late now.
But you got to go back.
But you have this to go to
the next one.
Have another party next week.
Thank you very much.
Congratulations. Thank you.
Good job!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Can I have a hug?
-Yeah, of course.
-Thank you.
-Fur and glitter and everything.
Well done, pal.
You rocked that out.